[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, настав час уроку англійської мови
мене звати Наталія школа давайте
почнемо сьогодні, ми продовжуємо розмову про
спорт, і це останній урок
у темі, тому сьогодні буде
багато переглядів  і давайте почнемо
з зображення, подивіться, що ви бачите,
це різні місця для спортивних
занять. Чи можете ви вгадати, які заняття
я бачу футбол плавання зараз це
водне поло що щодо цього це
баскетбол погодьтеся, що щодо цього зображення чи
можете ви вгадати  активність хокей
добре зроблено,
і що є номером два в середньому
боксі, ймовірно, кікбоксинг правильний і
що це за картинка, це насправді
новий вид спорту для вас ми ще не обговорювали
це, це гольф, так як ми називаємо
це місце, щоб ви вже  знаю, що
для футболу ми називаємо місце футбольним
полем або футбольним полем правильно, але давайте
почнемо з хокею, що ми використовуємо
для хокею,
це хокейний каток, тому повторюйте за
мною хокейний каток молодець
номер два, що це,
це ще раз боксерський ринг, фантастичний боксерський ринг,
переконайтеся, що ви вимовляєте
ці слова
правильно  вже
кажу, що це баскетбольне кільце ні,
це не
баскетбольне поле, ні це не баскетбольне поле,
повторюйте за
мною баскетбольний майданчик і знову молодець
баскетбольний майданчик, що буде далі для гольфу,
що ми використовуємо для гольфу та поля для гольфу
ще раз  поле для гольфу добре зроблено,
а останнє, так що це
водне поло та басейн для водного поло, цей жіночий басейн, тож
давайте ще раз скажемо, що басейн для поло, басейн для водного
поло, добре зроблений, тепер давайте переглянемо
всі слова хокейний каток боксерське ринг
футбольне поле баскетбольне поле гольф
курс і басейн для водного поло
добре зроблено, а тепер давайте займатися цими
вправами один за одним, тож перш за все
хокейний ринг, як називається
вид спорту та яке обладнання нам потрібно для
це ви можете мені допомогти, давайте переглянемо це
так, це хокей, а для
хокею нам потрібен епік з ключками і сітка,
що таке сітка, подивіться, це комар,
тож скажімо речення, яке вам потрібно зіграти
мм-хм, чи можна  скажи, тобі потрібна ключка
на шайбу і сітка, щоб грати в хокей
і хокейний каток молодці давайте
перейдемо на боксерський ринг, як називається
цей вид спорту і яке спорядження
нам потрібно для цього
Браво це бокс кікбоксинг і  для
цього нам потрібен боксерський мішок і боксерські
рукавички, тож скажімо речення, що вам
потрібен боксерський мішок і боксерські рукавички, два ящика,
ми не говоримо
грати в бокс, тому що ми не граємо в боксерські
відьми, які роблять книги, тож вам знову потрібен
боксерський мішок і  боксерські рукавички дві книги
давайте перейдемо до того, що це за
Brava, тому назва спорту -
футбол, і для цього виграти футбол
і сітка ще раз скажемо
фантастичне речення,
вам потрібен футбол і сітка, щоб грати у
футбол,
давайте рухатися на баскетбольному майданчику що
це назва спорту Brava та
екв  уіпмент фантастичний, тому м'яч і обруч
ми не називаємо це вбивством сітки, це
баскетбольна сітка винна, тому нам потрібні м'яч
і кільце, щоб грати в баскетбол, тепер
ваша черга сказати ідеально, давайте перейдемо до
басейну для водного поло, то що таке
назва спортивного водного поло і що нам
потрібно для нього: м'яч, сітка та окуляри, щоб
захистити наші очі, тому що коли ви граєте у
водне поло, іноді ви можете піти
під воду, тому скажімо речення, вам
потрібен м'яч, сітка та окуляри, щоб грати у
воду  поло ваша черга сказати
речення, дуже дякую, тому
останнє поле для гольфу як називається
спорт хороший гольф і що нам потрібно, щоб
грати в гольф
давайте подивимося добре, нам потрібно багато
м'ячів і нам потрібні ключки  ключки,
якими ви граєте в гольф, називаються клюшками,
давайте повторимо ключки і скажемо
речення, щоб
грати в гольф, вам потрібні м'ячі та клюшки, ваша черга,
дуже дякую, тепер давайте подивимося на
цей вид
спорту знову хокей бокс футбол
баскетбол гольф та водне поло  Я хочу
, щоб ти  чорнило про цю діяльність та
подібні й різні види у всіх видах спорту,
тож, наприклад, якщо ми говоримо про м'яч,
чи використовуємо ми м'яч скрізь, граючи
в спорт, і робимо це в цих портах ні, ми
не використовуємо м'яч для боксу та не
використовувати м'яч для хокею, що ми використовуємо
прямо в парку,
тож давайте напишемо таблицю з подібними
речами, однаковими ідеями та різними
речами, скажемо схожими та різними що
схоже для всіх цих видів спорту скажемо,
що це спорт
подібна функція, що ще ви можете
займатися цим видом спорту на відкритому повітрі та в приміщенні
як басейн для водного поло може бути всередині
будівлі, так і зовні будівлі, а також
із полем для гольфу, ви можете грати в гольф
всередині, якщо це, наприклад, міні-гольф,
тому я б намалював, що ви  вмію займатися
спортом на відкритому повітрі та в приміщенні, ви знаєте,
давайте перейдемо до того, що відрізняється, тому ми
використовуємо м'яч для яких видів спорту давайте
назвемо його м'яч для футболу баскетбол
водне поло та гольф правильно
ми не використовуємо м'яч під час боксу та
простого  я  хокей, що ще, якщо ми говоримо
про командні види спорту та індивідуальні види спорту,
то що це з них
знову командні види спорту футбол баскетбол водне
поло та хокей, якщо говорити про гольф
і бокс, бокс більш індивідуальний.
Правильно, гольф може бути командним видом спорту, коли у
вас  команда різних гравців у гольф, які
грають у гольф, але я б сказав, що це
індивідуально, тому що це один гравець, який
займається цим видом спорту, добре, тому давайте запишемо
це, давайте будемо особливістю номер один
особливість номер два командні види спорту
хокей футбол баскетбол водне поло
індивідуальний вид спорту
бокс  і гольф добре, то що ще
схоже чи відмінне для цих видів спорту чи
можемо ми цим спортом займатися в Україні так ми
робимо, щоб всі ці види спорту існують в Україні
я запишу це два три,
тому є завдання для вас, зараз
подивіться ми  мати шість речень, і ми
маємо назви цих місць, тому я хотів би
, щоб ви доповнювали речення
словами зі списку, дозвольте мені прочитати
речення для вас номер один ми часто ходимо
плавати  а місцеве мм-хм, номер два
, це гольф на дев'ять або 18 лунок,
хм, номер три, давайте зустрінемося в
баскетбольному будинку після школи номер чотири,
лід звідси відкритий цілий рік,
номер п'ять, це її перший боксерський
бій у мм  -хм,
і останній, з яким ми не можемо грати у
футбол сьогодні, тому що вони
перефарбовують рядки, тому тридцять секунд
подумайте над словами
[Музика]
готові перевірити, давайте підемо номер один, ми
часто ходимо плавати в місцевому басейні
правильно так для  плавання ми використовуємо басейн
номер два, це 9 лунок або 18
лунок, пори для гольфу добре зроблені і лунки
, це маленькі місця, де
м'яч номер три, давайте зустрінемося на
баскетбольному полі,
що так, давайте зустрінемося на баскетбольному
майданчику після школи номер чотири
каток відкритий цілий рік, номер п'ять,
це її перший боксерський бій на рингу,
і останній, на який ми не можемо грати сьогодні на
футбольному полі, тому що вони
добре перефарбовують лінії, тому якщо
всі ваші відповіді правильні, ви можете
дай свій  ельф десять балів давайте перейдемо до ще
одного завдання сьогодні ми переглянули тему
спорт, це буде багато видів
діяльності, тому подивіться, давайте переглянемо
деякі прийменники, і давайте почнемо
з першого речення, ви захоплюєтеся
спортом або спортом так
, ви любите  про спорт, це
правильна відповідь,
я захоплююся спортом номер два, у якому
виді спорту вам подобається брати участь
найбільше або в якому виді спорту найбільше подобається брати участь у
другому так, правильна відповідь
у давайте ще раз прочитаємо питання, яким
видом спорту вам подобається займатися  у найбільш
і номер три який вид спорту вас
цікавить чи малювання в
майбутньому який правильний прийменник
тут так у давайте прочитаємо питання,
який вид спорту вам цікаво спробувати
в майбутньому номер чотири, на вашу
думку, що є ключем до  або два
набирання
форми правильна відповідь дві. Давайте прочитаємо
питання, на вашу думку, що є ключем
до формування форми, і останнє,
які травми отримують професійні
спортсмени або  на ризик, який, на вашу
думку, правильний прийменник тут
так на, тож давайте ще раз прочитаємо питання,
які травми
під загрозою для професійних спортсменів, а тепер давайте відповімо на це
запитання, тому я захоплююся спортом, що
це означає, ти любиш спорт це
твій улюблений я не захоплююся спортом мені
подобається
я люблю займатися йогою я хотів би спробувати,
мабуть, kangoo jumps в майбутньому, але
я не можу сказати, що я захоплююся спортом, а
ти добре номер два, який вид спорту
подобається  брати участь у більшості для мене
це йога, а ви, тому я б
сказав, що мені подобається брати участь у йозі номер
три, який вид спорту зацікавлений
спробувати в майбутньому, як я вже згадував
для мене, це стане хорошим стрибком,
тому я можу сказати  Мені цікаво спробувати
kangoo jumps у майбутньому,
а ти молодець, номер чотири, на вашу думку,
що є ключем до приходу у форму,
тож ключ до приходу у форму, щоб повернутися
до своєї форми, обкладинка нового тизеру чи офіційного,
що таке  для мене ключ до того, щоб бути у формі
займається спортом і здоровою їжею,
звичайно правильно, і рухатися кожен
день, так що ви згодні зі мною, дякую
і останній, які травми піддаються
професійним спортсменам, тому
професійні спортсмени вони
бігають, вони бігають, вони говорять, вони стрибають у висоту, тому я
думаю, що вони можуть отримати травми, це
дуже небезпечний вид спорту, тому, ймовірно, вони
можуть зламати ноги, вони можуть
зламати руки, це
наступна тема, продовжимо розмову про
захист себе та різні
травми, тепер для вас є ще одне завдання
, подивіться, у нас є  електронний лист від
Анни до Дейзі, і знову у нас є кілька
прийменників, і нам потрібно вибрати
правильні, тому я даю вам одну хвилину,
перегляньте електронний лист і виберіть
правильний прийменник, будь ласка, переконайтеся,
що ви уважно прочитайте його
[Музика]
[Музика],
тож давайте  прочитайте текст разом, але
перед цим
давайте перевіримо правильні відповіді,
подивіться, перша в наступній є
власним номером три в номері чотири на
номері п'ять поза номером шість - і  номер
сім в тож давайте разом прочитаємо текст
привіт, Дейзі, ти цікавишся
спортом. Зазвичай я не захоплююся фізичними вправами,
але мені подобається брати участь у заняттях зумби, які
я почав у вересні минулого року. Я пробув
у бабусі й дідуся ціле літо, і
вони вдягалися  трохи важить моя
бабуся чудово готує, мені насправді потрібно було
купити новий одяг, але я все відкладав це
, тому що ненавиджу ходити по магазинах, я радий, що
зробив, тому що натомість знайшов Бійцівський клуб,
і це чудово, що це тренування,
яке багато  Особисто весело, я вважаю,
що ключ до того, щоб бути у формі, – це
розважитися, а також, на відміну від більшості видів спорту, ти
не ризикуєш отримати травму, тому що ти можеш працювати
у своєму власному темпі, ти маєш піти зі мною
і спробувати коли-небудь,
дякую Анна, тому, як ви бачите з
електронною поштою ми маємо всі відповіді на наші
попередні запитання, тож чи Анна захоплюється
спортом, вона зазвичай не захоплюється фізичними вправами,
але їй подобалося брати участь у Zumba, коли
вона почала відвідувати заняття Zumba так у
вересні минулого року, і ще одне запитання,
чому с  він трохи набрав ваги Браво,
тому що її бабуся чудово готує,
моя бабуся і моя мама
також чудово готують, і я люблю готувати,
давайте йти далі,
тому говорити про Бійцівський клуб це
приємний досвід для Ани, їй це подобається,
і вона  співає, що це також дуже весело
, і це дуже безпечно, тому що
ви можете працювати у своєму власному темпі, і вона
вважає, що немає ніяких травм,
це абсолютно безпечно, зараз
є останні дії, які
ми спробуємо сьогодні, це  це буде
гра у відгадки,
тому я напишу кілька слів із
теми спорт, використовуючи різні види спорту та
обладнання, і вам потрібно вгадати
слово готове, давайте, так що одна два три
чотири п’ять букв у словах, і вони
дадуть вам підказку  буква P знаходиться
в середині чи можете ви вгадати слова,
це слово добре зроблено ще одне слово
готуйтеся один два три чотири знову п'ять
букв, але тепер буква P стоїть в
кінці що таке слово є слово
суд Браво, тепер є  буде
дуже  цікаве слово
один два три чотири букви, мабуть, ти
можеш сказати Наталя пул ні перша
буква П, але остання буква о, ти можеш
вгадати слово бола, добре зроблено, ще одне
слово для тебе один два три чотири літери
і перша буква знову П  це
не басейн, я дам вам підказку, що тут є
буква C, і ми використовуємо це для
хокейної шайби, добре виконано, і останнє слово
з чотирма літерами це не бик,
перша буква C
так, це клуб, тому слово клуб  може бути
іншим, це може бути клуб Zumba, це
може бути бійцівський клуб, або це може бути
палиця, яку ви використовуєте для гри в гольф, тож
дозвольте мені дати вам довші слова один два
три чотири п'ять шість сім вісім і
букви так п'ять секунд, щоб  вгадайте,
п’ять, яке у них слово футбол, давайте
запишемо це, і у мене є запитання,
це спорт чи обладнання, скажімо, я б
напишу статтю тут, і це
буде обладнання F-футбол, яке ми використовуємо
для гри у футбол, тому футбол для
футболу як  Я вже згадував, що ми використовуємо
футбольний мяч  я і ми граємо в стерву, що
щодо корту,
що це так, це баскетбольний
майданчик, давайте переглянемо, що ще нам потрібно,
щоб грати в баскетбол м'яч і обруч
Браво
Сан-Паулу це водне поло де ми
граємо у водне поло так ми використовуємо воду
поло, що нам потрібно від
спорядження, нам потрібна сітка, м'яч і моє
улюблене слово
давайте почнемо з G і мурашка з нами, що
це за окуляри Bravo, і давайте закінчимо парк,
де ми використовуємо парк для хокею і
де ми використовуємо годинник під час гри в
гольф, велике дякую, я думаю, що
ви повністю оснащені темою «
Спорт», і, як я вже згадував, нова
тема почнеться з
наступного уроку, тепер я чую дзвінок,
це означає, що  нам потрібно припинити урок,
дуже дякую і побачимося
наступного разу до побачення
[Музика].